brain cleaning is in the air and i am
hot to trot it's why i'm so excited to
share with you a company i have been
working with i was first a customer
before i actually became a partner and
now our show is working with them too
they are called grove co and all of
their household products are sustainably
powerful and they have 100 natural
fragrances no harsh chemicals and by
2025 they will be completely plastic
free they are almost already there
they actually have a whole recycling
program
and this is absolutely my favorite
product this uh multi-purpose cleaning
spray is a game changer and it comes in
this gorgeous bottle and even the
refills come in these little baby glass
bottles that i love so much again no
plastic
so you would take your bottle of water
and then you add in the cleaning
solution
and
there's scents
oh god so good
their scents are so beautiful
and then what you want to do is i
actually buy their bamboo toilet paper
because i want to like save a tree and
they make paper towels out of bamboo as
well but these are actually my new
favorite the european dishcloth because
what you do is when you wet it
it's so much more powerful than a paper
towel it's like a chamois and you use
them and they're great they're absorbent
they're malleable and then you can pop
them in the washer and voila no paper or
trees wasted either i know
but i have to tell you
that
another way that grove educated me is um
they have something i haven't seen from
any other company these are laundry
detergent sheets
so
no plastic
it's amazing they're so effective you
put them in with your clothes voila
everything comes out perfect it makes me
feel so good about the way i'm living my
life and i just believe in this company
so much and they are the solution that i
want to share with you guys another
thing that i'm highly addicted to is
fabric softener so i found these wool
dryer balls now you can just put one in
um per load but i want that effect that
really good fabric softener does and
these have it and they're totally eco
and they're amazing and they're really
really they really get the job done and
once again i'm like i am living that
life i am walking the walk and i'm
talking the talk and it empowers me and
it puts a smile on my face i'm so
excited and passionate to share this
information with you and the truth is
you are all going to go home with these
dryer balls and laundry sheets so that
you
can do this and we can all do it
together
literally
we can all make small changes this month
to be more sustainable and these are the
products i use in my home because they
are so earth friendly and beautiful and
effective and everything at grove.com is
amazing and you should go shop it it's
got a very diverse portfolio of products
that they sell including their own lines
[Music]
you